we live in a time of fear and our
response to fear can either be to
contract and attempt to God ourselves or
to extend ourselves hold on to each
other and face our fears together what
is your instinct
what do you see more of in the world the
problem with the first approach is that
in our mounting isolation we divide
ourselves from others our sense of
isolation grows because our imagination
goes into overdrive about the people and
the spaces that we no longer engage with
our sense of other nests grows and we
lose empathy today I'm going to tell you
about a group of people that took the
global challenge of terrorism and began
creating spaces where strangers connect
and solidarity my own obsession was what
I see as irrational divisions began as a
child as a fourth generation Kenyan
Muslim of Indian origin it bothered me
that in four generations there wasn't a
single marriage in my family outside of
my small religious community and I
wondered what that was about was it fear
it was at racism was it cultural
preservation did it have something to do
with colonialism certainly we didn't
share a lot of the same public spaces
with others these divisions bothered me
deeply and they drove my career choices
when I was 20 the u.s. embassies in
Kenya and Tanzania were bombed a year
later I was on my way to the Middle East
to study conflict resolution and then
from that point on it wasn't very hard
for me to find in secure environments to
work in because the world was quickly
shifting in what we now know as the time
of terrorism I was in Washington DC when
9/11 happened and then I moved back home
to Kenya to work with refugees
and then later worked in Pakistan and in
Afghanistan in all of these places what
I noticed was how important physical
spaces are to making us feel safe
and well and like we belong in 2013 I
came back home to Nairobi from
Afghanistan al-shabaab operatives had
besieged Westgate shopping center
killing 67 people in a day of utter
horror soon after that I could see how
Nairobi was beginning to change and it
was beginning to feel more like the fear
and terror weary and war-torn cities
that I had worked in and Nairobi
continues to grow in fear driven ways we
see more walls more barriers more
security and like other parts of the
world we are experiencing an erosion of
human connection divisions along
religious lines are deepening and we're
doubting more and more how much we have
in common we are at a pivotal time when
we need to restore our confidence in
humanity and stand boldly and visibly
together
so in 2014 I brought together a group of
people in Nairobi to figure out what to
do public intellectuals diplomats
artists development workers and the
group articulated our challenge as
threefold one to reclaim the city from
the narrative of terrorism and back into
the hands of the people that live there
to introduce a language beyond race
tribal religion that would help us
transcend our differences and three
provide a gesture that would help
restore empathy and conversation and
trust one of the people in this group
was an artist and architect Osmani
Arboleda he and I have collaborated in
other parts of the world over many years
he has a history of disrupting urban
environments and making strangers
connect in incredible beautiful
spectacular ways he had an idea the idea
was to unite people of different faiths
by getting them to paint each other's
houses of worship mosques temples
synagogues churches paint them yellow in
the name of love but getting people to
focus on by focusing on icons of faith
we would get people to re-examine the
true essence of their faith the common
beliefs that we share in kindness
generosity and friendship by creating
pathways between houses of worship
within one neighborhood we would create
islands of stability and networks of
people that would would start without
that could withstand threats and
neighbors by picking up a paintbrush
with other neighbors would engage not
just with their heads but with their
hands and with their hearts and the
painted buildings would become
sculptures in the landscape that speak
of people from very different
backgrounds that stand together we'd
call the project color and faith we love
the idea and we immediately began
approaching houses of worship churches
temples mosques synagogues door-to-door
we went to more than 60 near a buys in
moms pastors and priests as you can
imagine bringing these communities
together when prejudices are reinforced
by a global pandemic of fear is not easy
it was complicated we were confronted
with the hierarchy of decision-making
within religious establishments for
example with Catholic churches we were
told that the archbishop would have to
make a decision and so we wrote a letter
to the archbishop we wrote a letter to
the Vatican and we're still waiting to
hear back and with other houses of
worship we were told that the patrons
the people that pay for the building and
the construction and the painting of the
buildings would have to make a decision
and then we came head to head with the
long legacy of missionary and donor
dependence that so impedes unconditional
civic action and we learned this the
hard way there's one community that in
our repeated conversations would keep
asking
to appreciate them and so we would keep
going back and telling them that we
appreciate them and of course if we
didn't appreciate them we wouldn't be
here and then we learned painfully late
in the game that the word appreciation
is code for getting paid to participate
and so we challenged them and we asked
the question so what will it cost how
much could we pay you and if we pay for
your faith is it really faith we started
the project asking the question where
does your face live and here we found
ourselves asking the question how much
does your faith costs but the most
difficult issue was the perceived risk
of standing apart we had one synagogue
that flat-out refused to participate
because it feared drawing attention to
itself and becoming a target similarly
we had a mosque that also feared
becoming a target and these fears are
justified and yet there were 25 houses
of worship that pledged to participate
these bold leaders took the gesture and
reinforced it with their own meaning for
some it was to tell the world that
they're not terrorists for others it was
to welcome people through their doors to
ask questions
and for some it was to bridge the gap
between the older and the younger
generation which by the way is something
that many faiths are grappling with
right now and for some it was simply to
build neighborhood solidarity in advance
of feared election violence when asked
why yellow one in mom beautifully said
yellow is the color of the Sun the Sun
shines on us all equally it does not
discriminate he and others spread the
word through their congregations and
over the radio municipal government
officials stepped forward and helped
with permits and with convening civil
society organizations
company donated a thousand liters of
yellow paint mixed especially for us and
what they now call optimistic yellow Ana
poetry collective joined forces with a
university and hosted a series of tweet
chats that challenged the nation and
issues of faith our face not just in the
context of religion but our faith in
politicians and in tribe and nature and
our faith in the older generation and in
the younger generation and then color
and faith was launched at a gallery
event that invited an incredible mix of
gallery goers and religious leaders and
artists and businesspeople already even
before picking up a paintbrush we had
accomplished so much of the conversation
and connection that we had hope for him
and then we began to paint Muslims stood
by Christians and atheists and agnostics
and Hindus and painted a mosque yellow
and then they all came together again
and painted a church yellow and then
another mosque and then another Church
poets and musicians performed while we
painted we painted in Nairobi and then
we painted in Mombasa the local and
international press did features and
color and faith in English and French
and Swahili and Spanish and Somali CNN
highlights at color and faith as a way
of bringing communities together and our
social media platforms lit up connecting
more and more people and these neighbors
continue to stay in touch there are some
that are pursuing politics with a
platform of peace and we have
communities as far as Argentina in the
US and as close as Miley and Rwanda that
are asking for our help and we would
love to help it's our dream that this
project this idea spreads across the
world
or without our support color and faith
is literally highlighting those who mean
well in yellow color and faith is
binding neighborhoods together and it's
our hope that when threats come knocking
they will collectively sift fact from
rumor and stand in solidarity we've
proven that the human family can come
together and send a message far brighter
and more powerful than the voices of
those that wish to do us harm those fear
is infectious we're showing that so is
hope thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you